quieren presentarlos como evidencia de
crímenes de guerra cometidos por Rusia
en este lugar denominado cementerio de
misiles por los ciudadanos de harkif hay
bombas de racimo proyectiles de cohetes
y fragmentos de misiles del ejército
ruso
en total en la ciudad de la región de se
registraron más de 5000 actos delictivos
en el registro Estatal de acuerdo con el
artículo 438 del Código Penal de Ucrania
violaciones en tiempos de guerra Rusia
uso Estas armas para atacar
infraestructura civil pacífica
hospitales de Gran altura bloques de
viviendas negocios privados y estatales
que no tienen nada que ver con la
infraestructura militar
la segunda ciudad más grande de Ucrania
vivió durante meses ataques con
artillería y municiones prohibidas por
las leyes internacionales los ataques
que llegaron a zonas altamente pobladas
por civiles podrían catalogarse como
crímenes de guerra una tarea asignada a
los expertos de la Corte Penal
Internacional que desde marzo inició sus
investigaciones
los esfuerzos del pueblo ucraniano han
hecho eco en todo el mundo en Londres la
primera dama de Ucrania o Lena selenska
inauguró una exposición que relata los
crímenes de Rusia desde el inicio de la
guerra
desde el 24 de febrero del 2022 hemos
sido testigos del genocidio y de los
crímenes de guerra cometidos por Rusia
contra el pueblo ucraniano esta
exposición muestra la realidad muestra
las atrocidades cometidas contra los
civiles y la destrucción de sus vidas
mientras los soldados y civiles sufren
las consecuencias de los ataques a las
principales plantas eléctricas del país
con el frío y la oscuridad como
aparentes estrategias de guerra de las
tropas de Vladimir Putin